if you have a Big Five personality
assessment on somebody before you
interview them
it's very it would be very useful if
you're about to interview somebody who's
high in extroversion you need to know
that during that interview you're going
to have an inflated view of their
competence
because you will automatically conflate
confidence with confidence if somebody
is high in neuroticism it's good to know
that in advance they might not appear
very confident they might require a
certain amount of coats Coke coaxing to
um to come out of their shell they might
be nervous it would be useful to have a
tool to know that in advance so you can
essentially
um
counteract the hard wiring that you have
as an interviewer you talked about
brutal selection methods and people
might react to that and I would say well
here's something for people to think
about hire stupidly and put people in
positions where not only do they fail
painfully over a long period of time but
they compromise the performance of
everyone around them while doing so it
isn't whether it's brutal or not it's
like which form of brutality do you
prefer and I would prefer the preventive
brutality approach rather than the
consequential brutality approach
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I recently had the
wherewithal and the honor and the
privilege to discuss the
business and research and personal
Arrangements that I've had with a couple
of my closest compatriots Dr Robert Opel
my former graduate advisor at McGill
University and my my former student Dr
Daniel M Higgins who graduated from MIT
and under my supervision from Harvard
we walked through our business
professional and personal relationships
as they've unfolded through many ups and
downs
over the last 30 years I and and uh
I wanted to bring them into the picture
because I have worked with them so
closely I've worked with them
particularly on two projects that I
wanted to also draw attention to as they
form the basis for much of the
discussion that's to follow this clip
one is
self-authoring.com
self-authoring as in s-e-l-f authoring
as in writing self-authoring.com and it
contains a number of programs past
present and future authoring that help
people write out The Narrative of their
life
their biography
their virtues and faults in the present
and then a vision for the future and
that's a very useful program as you do
live out a story and it's a good idea to
know what story you've been living out
and know where you want to go in the
future and that's self-authoring.com and
the other project that we developed on
the commercial front so that's publicly
accessible is understand
myself.com and understand myself
provides a very thorough description of
the fundamental elements of human
personality the five major traits
extroversion neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness and openness
differentiated into 10 different aspects
so it gives you a relatively simple
shorthand for your personality but also
a differentiated view of who you are and
so if you take that test which doesn't
take very long
about 20 minutes or so then you get a
detailed description of your
your basic temperament but also if you
have a partner and then your partner
takes the test then you can join the
test together and get a separate
um print out a separate report that
details your comparative similarities
and differences and this is extremely
useful it it's when you when you
establish an intimate relationship with
someone
there is some utility in your
differences and some utility in your
similarities and there's some additional
utility and understanding what those are
because you need to understand who your
partner is and you need to understand
when they're different from you that
they're actually different and that
there can be value in that and so
understand myself.com can help you
understand who you are it can help you
understand who your partner is and it
can understand how you differ and what
you might do about that and so well with
that we'll move onward to the discussion
itself so that self-authoring.com past
present and future biographical writing
and the development of a vision and
understand myself.com which helps you
understand your personality and maybe
understand your personality in
relationship to the person who's closest
to you so thank you all for your time
and attention and onward to the
discussion
so today I have
two people to talk to who who I know who
I've known for for many many years uh
first Dr Robert peel who was my graduate
supervisor at McGill from 1985 to 1992.
and with whom I've had a friendship and
business relationship ever since very
intense and multi-dimensional
relationship both on the intellectual
well on the intellectual front the
personal front and the business front
and so we're going to talk a little bit
about that today and also Dr Daniel
Higgins who is a student of mine at
Harvard after uh getting his engineering
training at Trinity and at
MIT and who also got involved with Bob
on the business front and helped me
develop help me and Bob develop some of
the
measurement devices that we've been
attempting to use in the corporate world
and more successfully using in the
private sphere and so I thought it would
be well fun for me but also hopefully
for for my two guests and for everyone
listening to just walk through what
we learned as we've worked together over
the last
30 years on the scientific front and the
business front I started working with
Bob in 1985 I wrote him a weird letter
when I was applying for
my graduate
training I'd finished my pH or my
bachelor's degree in Psychology my
second
update really to my first bachelor's
degree concentrating on psychology and
decided I wanted to go to clinical work
and I wrote him uh everyone I applied to
a letter that actually told people what
I was like which I'm sure scared off a
hell of a lot more people than it
attracted but for some reason it seemed
to Twig Bob's interest and he called me
one day
I really wanted to go to Montreal to
study and asked me if I wanted to come
down and study alcoholism we actually
had a compatriot in in uh common a man I
had met in Fairview years ago the town I
grew up in uh happened to be a student
of Bob's and when the letter showed up
on his desk
he
he asked this person Dave Ross if he
knew who I was and luckily I got a
positive review which was quite the
surprise
so I really enjoyed working with Bob
what do you remember from the beginning
of those days Bob
uh well first of all I remember the
letter uh and I remember that colleagues
uh advised me that I should not select
you as a graduate student
but it was exactly the non-traditional
nature of what you wrote
and the deep thought that was implicit
in your statements that Drew me to it
um
and uh
that along with a Basic Instinct to be a
risk taker was the reason why I accepted
you as a student
yeah well you know I I spent a lot of
time thinking about that letter A
because it was a calculated risk I think
I wrote If I remember and I can actually
remember some of this I think I wrote
that I like to drink copious amounts of
red wine and could type like a mad dog
and uh I knew that wasn't exactly
standard graduate school application
letter language but you know I thought
first of all I also indicated in a
letter that there were some deep things
that I wanted to pursue you know that I
was interested in assessing the nature
of human malevolence and and that I had
broad philosophical and psychological
interests so there was a real serious
part and there was a real
I I would say well comedic part in some
sense and provocative and I thought look
I'm going to be working with someone for
a long time and
I want to find someone who actually
wants to work with me and so
it was it was it was a calculated risk
like the one you took I guess when you
accepted me and it's funny you know
because people have had that kind of
reaction to me I would say ever since
which is that some people like you are
quite happy with the opportunity to work
with me and other people think you know
that they should keep me at a distance
with a stick and uh I think maybe it's
not obvious that the loud people in the
ladder Camp are wrong anyways
um yeah so you called me up and asked me
if I wanted to do some work on
alcoholism which wasn't really the
specific field that I had
events a tremendous amount of interest
in although it was interested in
motivation but we started to work on
on motivation for for drug and alcohol
abuse and on anti-social Behavior pretty
much right away why do you think our
collaboration was so successful
oh well it comes down to
to who you are and how many degrees of
freedom you're allowed
and the nature of the challenge and
challenges in front of you Jordan uh uh
are are produced great rewards so
I I think it's as simple as that
yeah well for me you know I was really
thrilled that I had the opportunity to
come to McGill I really wanted to come
to Montreal
and then you were an ideal supervisor
for me
because you were very practically
oriented right you had a great
administrative hand you had a thriving
and unbelievably productive lab how many
papers have you published Bob
um I honestly don't know George
uh 100 and a half 200 something like
that
yeah I think it's more than that Bob
so
yeah so so Bob's lab was famous for its
productivity I would say and and also
for the
for the morale of its graduate students
I mean one of the things that was really
remarkable about you and often in
distinction to other graduate
supervisors is that you were very
generous with credit
you know and you gave your students a
tremendous amount of freedom
and you really helped all of us through
the various administrative hurdles you
know clearing the ethics uh hurdles for
our research and then
encouraging us both simultaneously on
the career development and the
intellectual development front which is
a very
Thin Line ethically right because
obviously
to be a successful academic there is
kind of a marketing element you you have
to publish you have to meet people you
have to communicate but at the same time
you're supposed to be assiduously produ
pursuing
mathematically grounded truth insofar
say as you're a good statistician and
those often come into conflict and you
are very very good at letting all of us
know I mean you've produced a lot of
very successful graduate students uh
Sherry Stewart and Patricia conrod and
Josh again and Peter Finn a lot of very
successful academics and you did an
extremely good job of helping us know
that it was our moral obligation to
stick with the data no matter what but
at the same time to develop our careers
and for me also the fact that you had an
unbelievably encyclopedic knowledge of
the relevant psychiatric and
psychological research was that was
extremely useful it made our discussions
extremely fruitful because I could talk
about more philosophically oriented
issues and you could immediately bring
that down
well bring it down move laterally into
the scientific realm and help introduce
me into the approach to the appropriate
biological and psychiatric literature
[Music]
the current administration's New Year's
goals are to tax spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation if this is at odds with
your goals if you are tired of the
government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plans then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
crashes with help from the experts at
Birch gold you can own gold and attack
sheltered retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA in Precious Metals just text
Jordan to 989898 to claim your free info
kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metal Specialists Birch
gold will hold your hand through the
entire process text Jordan to 989898 and
protect yourself with gold today with an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings text Jordan to
989-898 today
[Music]
two rules of thumb uh first was accept
good students and get out of their way
that is just provide them with what they
need to do what they're interested in
and secondly
if they have really good ideas
um don't ask the bureaucrats just do it
yeah well you know as we work together
that got more and more difficulty and we
could tell even back then that the
University was starting to close in on
its researchers because when I first
started working with you the ethics
committees the so-called ethics
committees were kind of a encumbrance
that whose whose dictates you had to
please but could in some real sense
dispense with quite rapidly while
attempting to stay in the proper ethical
domain but as we continue to work
together the constraints that were
placed on our research became more and
more onerous and that's a process that's
just continued and accelerated since
then but you could really see it coming
back even in the
in the late 80s
yeah
no it's true
um
I I'm somewhat happier that I'm not
there now uh given the kinds of
constraints that researchers have to go
through
yeah well it's so odd day because as we
got more and more efficient at
running studies and this happened a lot
when I was working with Daniel too we
got more and more efficient had running
studies and designing them
partly as a consequence of being able to
use computational power
and so we could do studies much faster
the bureaucratic impediments to doing
studies multiplied to such a degree that
it became more and more difficult to do
them because of there were so many uh
hurdles that had to be left over before
you could even begin the process of an
investigation and so it's really hard on
people who are quick-minded and sharp
because
their orientation is to do interesting
things as rapidly as possible and then
to be confronted continually with a
bureaucracy that works out counter
purposes to that
certainly ensures at least to some
degree that anybody who's fast and sharp
just wants to get the hell out of there
yeah because you know you said this is
so cool one of your management
principles
and this is a good thing to pursue on
the
front of the joint relationship between
scientific scientific Endeavor and
entrepreneurial Endeavor he said your
management principle was to hire really
good people students let's say and then
get the hell out of their way and one of
the things I really admired about you
and never stopped admiring you for and
you were a great model in this regard
was that
you were
you know your students had areas of
expertise always that you didn't share
like Sega for example was a PR was a
near professional musician you tended to
take in a lot of students who had non
traditional backgrounds in some sense in
relationship to psychology and I never
ever saw you
what would you say
engaging in a Turf War for intellectual
preeminence with any of your students if
they were operating in an area of
expertise that wasn't your area of
expertise you know you you were always
able to
maintain like a calm Authority
and never be threatened by the fact that
you were willing and capable of bringing
around people bringing people around you
who knew some things you didn't know
that was early and that is a great
management principle
well less a principle and more a
realization that they were all brighter
than me yeah well that that remains to
be that remains to be determined so we
started working on alcoholism that was
really useful
useful saw alcohol unlike most other
drugs
doesn't really Target a specific brain
area or set of neurological receptors it
it flows through the brain like water
and one of the consequences for me was
that that meant that I really had to
delve deeply into biological
Neuroscience because
alcohol essentially affected every
physiological and neurophysiological
system in the body and so part of what I
learned to do at McGill apart from
developing a certain degree of
statistical expertise not my forte by
the way was to delve deeply into the
biological literature and you were very
interested in biological Psychiatry so
that was extremely helpful
yeah
remember that paper we did on genetics
for the U.S Congress
yeah
I was amazed at how quickly you were
able to grasp that literature
[Music]
um
and that was a very nice piece of work
yeah well it was one of the things that
that was great for me at McGill
you know there's this idea in um
psychology of construct validation and
the idea is you know how do you
determine if something that's abstract a
psychological concept let's say
like neuroticism or self-esteem how do
you know if that's real rather than just
sort of a metaphor or a linguistic
placeholder and one of the answers to
that is well it's real if it if it's a
pattern that makes itself manifest
across a variety of different modes of
measurement
and I had been reading a lot of
psychoanalytic material and mythology
when I came to McGill which definitely
put me in a minority and then as a
consequence of having the biological
Frontier opened up especially with
people like Jeffrey gray
I started to see parallels between the
Deep biological literature neural hard
Neuroscience work and animal
experimental work that was done on rat
brain functioning and and on the
neurochemical front I can start to see
real deep parallels between that and the
mythological material that I had been
reading and that was really what I
started writing my first book when I was
at Miguel maps of meaning and pursued
that a lot while I was working with you
sort of as a side project but
it was an attempt to integrate all the
biology I was learning about with the
with the mythology we're also studying
anti-social Behavior at that point in
this sort of segues into my relationship
with Daniel and we'll we'll get to that
or interrelationship so Bob and I were
working with with uh the sons of male
alcoholics who also had an extensive
family history of alcoholism a very
specific population that eventually
became essentially impossible as the
dictates came down from above that half
our research subjects had to be female
which was a real problem for our
research Enterprise because we were
actually researching a particular kind
of primarily male Psychopathology and
our subjects had to be young men who
weren't alcoholic
who did drink who had alcoholic fathers
alcoholic grandfathers so they had to
have an alcoholic father another close
elk and at least another close alcoholic
relative male and not an alcoholic
mother because that would have exposed
them in principle to fetal alcohol
syndrome and and we were looking at the
biological basis of the proclivity to
alcoholism
and uh
we're interested in the role of
disinhibition in that right so you might
say well one of the reasons people might
drink is because they're biochemically
responsive to alcohol in some manner
that's either directly rewarding like
cocaine or anxiety reducing like Valium
and barbiturates but another possible
hypothesis is they're just not very good
at impulse control
and so an Impulse would be a biological
impetus that wants short-term
gratification like lust or hunger or
thirst or the desire to breathe for that
matter and obviously you have to abide
by those dictates or you die but if you
only fall prey to them then you're
impulsive and that dysregulates your
medium to long-term survival so we're
interested in impulsivity Bob and I
started to investigate the
neuropsychological literature
a lot of people at McGill were working
on the assessment of so-called
prefrontal cognitive ability and had
developed a lot of practical tests for
brain damaged people to see what focal
cognitive deficits they had as a
consequence of their neurological
condition or their brain surgeon we
started to apply that to the analysis of
anti-social Behavior right and Jean
Segal was very much involved in that
so
what got you interested Bob in the in
the anti in the realm of anti-social
Behavior
well alcohol and aggression
the the relationship uh
if if you want to really understand
aggression
um understand the relationship between
alcohol aggression because alcohol is
involved in and and half of murders
rapes and uh General assaults but it was
most situations of violence
um and so it was a question of what is
alcohol doing to the brain that in fact
is increasing that propensity uh so uh
um
as we were turning to Sons of Alcoholics
then the problem of alcoholism it became
the same kind of question of was there a
difficulty in producing inhibitory
Behavior as these individuals also
tended to have a series of
cognitive deficits as measured in terms
of oh Scholastic performance and and
psychological tests
and so that's where you started looking
at the Montreal Neurological Institute
and uh the the measures that they were
using to measure for example frontal
lobe functioning as its importance in
generally controlling uh social behavior
right well that was the first that that
was the first paper I published with
Jennifer Jennifer rothfleisch and Phil
zelazo right we we put together a
neuropsychological battery and then we
had people who were drunk at two doses
of alcohol and we used high doses of
alcohol in our lab which was one of the
things that made it rather unique we
looked at the specific patterns of
neuropsychological deficits that alcohol
produced and alcohol doesn't interfere
with things like vocabulary
understanding or color perception but it
has a walloping effect on the ability to
move information from short-term storage
into long-term storage even at
relatively moderate Doses and it really
interferes with complex motor
coordination although it doesn't
suppress
um let's say it doesn't shorten it
doesn't lengthen reaction time per se
simple reaction time and had no effect
on at all that's right so we started
building a neuropsychological battery
first of all to see what the nature of
the overlap between criminal and
aggressive behavior and the proclivity
to alcoholism was but also trying to
investigate why alcohol made people
aggressive because it is one of the few
drugs and your research was was part of
what a demonstrated demonstrated this
that alcohol actually does make people
more aggressional aggressive I remember
a study we discussed that you devised
where
we people were put into a bus aggression
task I think where they were asked to
administer shocks electrical shocks of a
certain duration and intensity to their
competitors in a game-like scenario low
levels of shock and they weren't
actually shocking a real person that was
a sham but um one of the hypothesis was
that people who were drunk just didn't
know what they were doing so if I
remember correctly you had the drunks
the people who were alcohol intoxicated
write down or otherwise record the level
of shocks that they were administering
and the duration to make that conscious
and what happened was that actually made
the drunk people more aggressive rather
than less so it wasn't merely a matter
of alcohol induced stupidity it was
there was real facilitation of
aggression that seemed to be associated
with something like disinhibition
mm-hmm
indeed
um and you we even tried to pay them not
to be aggressive and uh found out that
that works very well with people who
generally have higher IQs but uh not
with individuals with lower IQs yeah
yeah well you know the thing is people
in the real life in some sense are paid
not to be aggressive when they're drunk
and the way you get paid to not be
aggressive well you're drunk is by not
getting in trouble and that certainly
doesn't stop people it's worth just
dwelling for a moment on the statistic
that Bob cited you know we did a lot of
reviews of the relationship between
alcohol and aggression and it's I think
you could make a pretty strong case that
almost all sexual assault and almost all
and a tremendous amount of General
interpersonal violence would just vanish
if people weren't
overly alcohol intoxicated there's a
massive relationship between drunkenness
what half the people who commit murders
are severely intoxicated and half of the
victims of violent crimes are severely
alcohol intoxicated
right it's indeed it's always been
amazing to me that when we talk about
sexual assault on campus you know we
talk a lot about sexism and not and
toxic masculinity and not very much
about
the fact that it's almost all alcohol
fueled
at least half of it is Jordan
yes right right at least half of it is
so
so we were also you and I were also
talking at that point about
entrepreneurial ideas you know because I
guess we both had a bit of an
entrepreneurial bent and one of the
things that was always noodling away at
us was whether there was anything that
we could do that might constitute the
grounds for the construction of a of a
business and I remember we talked about
the possibility of investigating
treatment for hangovers on the
pharmaceutical front and went down that
rabbit hole for a while but we never
really at McGill we never really
settled on an entrepreneurial idea I
think one of the ideas that we had
discussed too is to start a Consulting
business to help people who had health
problems do an objective review of the
scientific literature bearing on their
particular health problem and that's
still a good idea although we never did
do it and well anyways after I
was that Mcgill and I think Bob and I
wrote 15 papers together which was
something of a record at that point
um for a graduate student and and and
advisor collaborator
um I was
thrilled to receive an appointment to
Harvard which was quite yeah that was
quite the event and I went down and
started pursuing
the same line of research in some sense
that I was pursuing with you but it had
become increasingly difficulty National
Institute for alcoholism and alcohol
abuse which in principle was designed to
facilitate research
kept making it impossible to bring
people into the lab and actually give
them reasonable doses of alcohol I mean
I Remember by the time you and I were
done our research we were having to keep
our damn subjects in the lab for like
six or seven hours after we got them
drunk
the the ni AAA required that we bring
their their alcohol blood alcohol level
down I think their eventual
recommendation was either 0.04 or 0.02
half of legal intoxication they wouldn't
allow us for example to send them home
in a cabin nobody wanted to sit in our
damn lab and sober up miserably for six
hours you know while staring at a wall
and it made it pretty much impossible
to bring people in repeated times
because the experience became too
onerous and there was all sorts of other
restrictions that were emerging that
made
it made it impossible for us to do what
we had been doing and we we got a long
way on analyzing the effects of alcohol
associating with opiate reinforcement
and starting to investigate potential
biochemical treatments like Naltrexone
for alcoholism so it was and we did it
on a shoestring budget too which was
also an interesting thing to do no so I
went to Harvard and
I wasn't making a lot of money I had to
teach a lot of extra classes my wife
couldn't work because she didn't have a
green card and I was just kind of
existing on the threshold of
survivability you know in a in a
comfortable sense but but I didn't even
have magazine subscriptions when I was a
junior professor at Harvard and I rode
this old I drove this old rust bucket of
a car that was barely holding together
and uh I remember I phoned up the dean
at one day and I said uh you know I
don't know what your policy here is at
Harvard but you guys hired me to do
research but I have to do a lot of
overload teaching just to be able to
survive here because it's relatively
expensive like what the hell is the
rationale for this I was probably
slightly more polite than that and he
said well most of our people consult and
I thought well that's not true because
Junior professors don't have time to
consult so that's just not true but okay
if that's the damn game then what the
hell do I know that might have some
economic value and I thought we had
talked at that point about
starting to use our neuropsych battery
which we had started to computerize
on a on broader fronts right we used it
to investigate alcohol and then
anti-social personality
and then I thought
you know maybe we could see if this
battery
of neuropsychological tests would
predict corporate and academic
performance
and so I called you and and that's when
and we had to talk about you know
potentially putting together a company
that would be
designed to do exactly that
and we did like the late 1990s
yeah and that's when Daniel showed up
and so Daniel you had done a
you had done your engineering training
at Trinity
and then at MIT so let walk us through a
little bit about your about your
academic and intellectual background
um I was uh
I did uh civil engineering at Trinity
College in Dublin and then I uh came
over to the U.S
and um I found it was incredibly
difficult to find a job just to go
through the the mechanics of it so I
thought well maybe I'll just go to
graduate school instead which sadly it
was as shallow as that
um no it probably wasn't but uh I went
uh to uh MIT and I did a degree a
master's degree in civil engineering but
at the time it would have been around
1991 92 93 the use of computers computer
technology was getting cheaper and so it
was more pervasive and so obviously
while I'm there I'm not going to be
busting concrete beams or cubes I'm
going to be looking at what the um what
the current uh computer technology is AI
and so on and so forth the people were
much more optimistic about AI in the in
the early 90s than they were in the late
90s
and um and so I had been doing computer
programming and then uh I went over to
take some classes uh at Harvard with you
um I think the I think it was would have
been 1995.
I may have been in your first
personality psychology class or your
second I'm not quite sure
and we started uh programming the um the
the neuropsych
um stuff
um the work that that you guys had done
and the general Sagan had done in
Montreal had used a paper and pencil
version of the uh of the psych tests and
those psych tests were they were kind of
modified from uh use with people from
with clinical issues and with
experimental animals so it was it was an
interesting kind of a transformation of
using something to detect clinical
differences
um to detect individual differences and
at the time the idea of a prefrontal
cognitive ability really didn't as far
as I know it didn't really exist people
spoke about executive function but they
didn't speak about it in individual
differences terms
um they spoke about it more in a uh in a
sort of a global like what would happen
if executive function did or didn't
exist
and uh and so we were using we
computerized the uh the the types of
tests that you'd been using with the
sons of male alcoholics and that Johnson
had been using with I believe impulsive
children if I remember correctly yeah
and um and then uh we did the I think it
was 1997. we you were teaching the
personality uh class and we did the uh
online
computerized personality lab right right
which was um and that was early web days
and so we had we we did that we had uh I
guess we did like 100 experiments at
once we did something that was right
when net that's right when was it
Netscape what was the first browser it
would it was pretty much right after
right after nescape came out it was it
was fairly early
um in computer days it was when Pearl
was the way that you would do Pearl CGI
programming was the way you were doing
you do web stuff and um and so we
essentially set up a bunch of
experiments
um my wife Alice Lee and I programmed
them and um and all the kids in the
class took them um it was like I think
probably about 140 and they divide it up
into groups of five to do the analysis
so we did a soup uh Soup To Nuts
um uh set of uh as you said maybe 15 20
different experimental questions yeah
yeah yeah well it was and it was it was
this this battery of tests that I had
developed with Sega and Bob
um it took like a lot of it required
gadgets and lights and boxes and it was
very mechanical it also took about nine
to 11 hours for a trained
neuropsychologist to administer the test
battery but when we computerized we got
when we computerized it we got the whole
damn thing down to 90 minutes
and so then then we were interested in
we thought well we could use this
um test battery to assess
Psychopathology impulsivity but then
could we use it to assess normative or
even excellent performance
and Daniel and I and Bob started to
investigate the possibility of using
prefrontal cognitive ability tests to
assess academic prowess at Harvard and
out the University of Toronto as it
eventually turned out and we also
started to move into the corporate world
and so that was part of an
entrepreneurial Vision at that point as
well because we thought well
I I had started studying papers that
were produced by God now I'm not going
to be able to remember unfortunately the
names of the people who who who who
produced the initial equations relating
increased accuracy of selection to
economic
um
Hunter and Schmidt yeah uh absolutely
crucial papers showing that so one of
the things we learned for everyone
watching and listening is that a tiny
minority of extremely high performers
produce almost all the economic outcome
of a given Endeavor so it's actually the
square root of the number of people
involved in a given Endeavor do half the
work that's like the 80 20 rule is
almost a very small minority of your
customers produce all your profits a
small minority of your workers produce
all your productive outcome a small
minority of creative people produce
almost all the creative output a small
number of criminals
commit almost all the crimes and so what
that means is that if you can tilt your
selection methods your hiring methods
towards the upper end even a small
amount and thereby increase the number
of extremely top performers that you
have in your organization the economic
payoff to that is unbelievably dramatic
so I think Schmidt and Hunter estimated
at that point that if the U.S
bureaucracy the government bureaucracy
switched to Accurate assessment for
hiring which they're actually bound to
do by law they would save it amount each
year equivalent to Total American
corporate profits
and I read that and I thought oh my God
if we can develop a new way of assessing
ability
that's accurate we should be able to go
to corporations and say look you know
for a relatively small amount of money
we can radically increase the
productivity of your employees and I
thought we could just make a statistical
case that the payoff for that would be
so great that you know people would
literally be to pass to our door and so
that was a very naive presumption now
you were put right in the center of this
because in order to pursue this for your
for your PhD you decided to come and do
a PhD in Psychology you had to master
the neuropsychological literature you
had to master the literature on IQ
testing because one question that came
up was well was there a difference
between prefrontal cortical ability
let's say the ability cognitive
abilities that are dependent on the the
the forward part of the brain the part
that abstracts action before it's
implemented what was the relationship
between not an IQ and most of the
neuropsychologists regarded IQ tests as
these Dusty uh you know ancient
technologies that had been superseded
and just assumed that what they were
measuring was something separate but
that had never really been rigorously
tested and then you also had to become a
master of the relevant literature on
personality because personality traits
like conscientiousness are also useful
at predicting performance and so why
don't you talk a little bit about the
development of your thesis and also the
fact that you wrote your thesis at the
same time that the bell curve came out
and that was quite the political
nightmare All Things Considered so let's
why don't you walk through what you did
for your PhD research and your thesis
well we sort of hit a perfect storm in a
way because hernstein and Maurice bell
curve had just been published
which was the most vilified book of the
90s if you like
um and hernstein and Murray were both at
Harvard although hernstein had just
passed away and we had been the neural
psych guys had been speculating on
the way the brain works under normal
circumstances based on Research that
they had done with clinical populations
and they essentially completely ignored
the statistical methods that are
required to talk about individual
differences in cognitive ability and
individual differences and outcomes
differences across situations
and so in some ways we we we caught a
certain amount of flack from the
neuropsych guys because we weren't
cutting up monkeys which seems okay to
me
um but uh and they didn't they weren't
interested in the in the IQ stuff
because
the the intelligence research
had was tainted in Psychology it which
was very strange because it was the most
well developed
from a scientific perspective and has
been area of psychology
and the tools that people used
throughout psychology personality
psychology for example were developed by
the early intelligence researchers
um is Charles Spearman uh developed a
factor analysis and it was later
enhanced by um that gentleman from the
UK I've forgotten his name
but in Thurston is it Thursday
and um and so
it was very weird for somebody coming
into Psychology from um from engineering
to look at the situation and see well
the most rigorous research programs that
I can see in this this is probably going
to irritate experimental psychologists a
bit but I don't know how else to put it
um we're despised the area that that
those things that that was essentially
despised and um and
and
a lot of academics in psychology were
trying to figure out how to
um essentially
throw stones at intelligence research
even though it would be like that Meme
where it's like nobody nothing and then
Jerome Kagan IQ tests are biased
it was just it was that opportunistic it
just to just to come out and make it and
make a statement against that so
suddenly I found myself and you did also
um being with
um the pariahs when we didn't even know
that there was such a situation yeah
yeah it was really weird eh because in
existence we were driven
to 100 no we were driven by two things
like first of all
we had an entrepreneurial curiosity
about this but Bob and you and I were
driven I would say apart from that 100
percent by nothing but the desire to try
to find accurate predictors of
measurable performance academically and
and industrially there was no Not only
was there no political agenda as you
said we didn't even know a political
agenda existed in some real sense till
you started writing your thesis and the
bell curve issue blew up and we were
also interesting might people might find
this interesting so the
neuropsychologist had really claimed
that what they were measuring with their
specific tests was something completely
independent of IQ or at least
importantly independent of IQ and then
as we delved into the IQ research and
you took the Forefront on this uh
Endeavor Daniel we realized that
all cognitive measures converge to a
single factor and that really means all
right it means you can't come up with
the go ahead Daniel if you're
speculating about the higher cognitive
functions like Alexandra luria's the
higher cognitive functions of man and if
you're working in that tradition and you
want to you want to speculate about that
in intact humans you're like two
questions away from G essentially right
right you're like well how does this
manifest itself in the real world well
it manifests itself in individual
differences between between performance
okay and
what do those things have in common
a lot they're all inter they're all uh
positively correlated with each other
right you're a chi you bake
congratulations it's 1904 you've just
rediscovered the G Factor but yeah but
no we're not going to ask that second
question
we're just we're not even gonna ask the
first question we're just going to
speculate about
um about how important things like
executive function are without without
saying well can it be formalized
measured and does it um does it does it
spread are there individual differences
and then once you ask those questions it
is incumbent upon you to explain why it
is different than the G Factor right
right well that was hard on us too
because we had already put years into
working out the proposition that these
prefrontal cognitive tests were in fact
assessing something interestingly
different right and then I pushed when
we did go ahead I pushed the um
prefrontal cognitive ability as a
construct
um measure it by the um by the
neuropsych test that we had essentially
stolen from the um from the neuropsych
guys in the animal research guys
um and developed into an individual
difference construct and I pushed that
as far as I could as an independent
construct from G
um and when I wrote up my dissertation I
I and the paper the one that we
published in the Journal of Personality
and Social Psychology
um essentially I didn't collapse it and
I pushed it as hard as I could but after
coming away from that I I would not sit
down with anyone and tell them that
prefrontal cognitive ability was
independent of G because it had a
different Heritage yeah this is a good
indication of the kind of price you can
pay for scientific rigor I mean Bob and
I had put six years into the development
of this prefrontal cognitive battery and
there was some utility in it predicting
disinhibition and then you and I put in
years developing the battery itself and
then our Discovery was we didn't know
enough about the psychometrics of
intelligence to be doing what we were
doing and that there was no escaping
from the black hole of fluid
intelligence in some real sense I mean
we did get evidence that the battery had
incremental predictive validity in
relationship to predicting grades at
Harvard and the University of Toronto
and also on the corporate front but what
that meant at Best in all likelihood was
that perhaps we had expanded the domain
of cognitive measurement to some degree
into areas that hadn't been precisely
evaluated although it might have just
been that it was just a secondary
consequence of additional testing
[Music]
with the start of the New Year upon us
what better time than now to start
building a habit of Prayer just like
physical exercise daily spiritual
exercise is critical to your well-being
especially in a world where attacks on
faith and religion are happening all
around us every day
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the U.S and the number one
Catholic app in the world helps you
maintain a daily prayer routine
it's filled with studies meditations and
Reflections including the number one
Christian podcast the Bible in a year
download the app for free at hallow.com
Jordan you can set prayer reminders
invite others to pray with you and track
your progress along the way
make this year your year for spiritual
growth and peace get an exclusive
three-month free trial at hollow.com
Jordan that's hallow.com Jordan
well we we for our G measure of G we
only use you know the Ravens Progressive
Matrix right exactly you know the block
the fluid intelligence components like
three of them of the of the waste so
um a uh a real uh intelligence
researcher like Ian Drury for example is
that that's his name isn't it yeah Ian
jewelry
um he would say you haven't you haven't
tapped G at all you've only you've only
taken two or three subtests and he would
basically want to um to find the whole
thing but anyways one of the things that
you said at the time was every psych uh
experiment should use IQ tests
and that would have been
um if that if that Reese if that sort of
Maxim had been used from the start uh we
probably wouldn't have
um been as naive as we were about about
getting away from it that's not to say
that executive function and prefrontal
cognitive ability are reducible to some
magical construct in the sky gee um it's
just to say that uh in psychological
research things just don't fall along
the nice little neat theoretical lines
that you build your career around that
they're it's messy right yeah well what
I concluded at that time was that every
psychological experiment run that
involves analysis of the differences
between people
should buy what would you call Universal
Fiat be required to use both IQ tests
and and likely personality tests because
we have these basic constructs General
cognitive ability which is a walloping
measure and also pretty decent measures
of temperamental proclivity and they're
really basic the same way the elements
in the table of the elements are basic
physically and we shouldn't be talking
about any other constructs in Psychology
until we can be absolutely sure that
we're not just re-measuring constructs
that have already been discovered and
that is kind of disheartening on the
psychological front because both
IQ and the big five I mean you can argue
exactly about the parameters of the big
five still but fundamentally they're
such black holes that they tend to suck
in every other bit of research and and
invalidate it in some sense like I mean
I remember we looked at the self-esteem
literature for example and concluded
pretty rapidly that self-esteem was
nothing but
low neuroticism with a bit of
extraversion thrown in and there was no
need for the self-esteem construct at
all and I mean that just obliterates the
careers in some real sense of of the
people who are proposing these
alternative uh constructs as real the
other thing that happened Daniel when we
were at when we were working together
was that the multiple intelligence and
practical intelligence people especially
at the Harvard School of Education under
Gardner were beating their drum
extremely loudly and Gardner was
proclaiming that what had always been
regarded as talents there's multiple
talents let's say although they might be
United to some degree by G that he
proposed renaming talents intelligence
and then pursuing this multiple
intelligence idea which was really just
a political
scheme right from the beginning because
he never developed a single instrument
of measurement and that was scandalous
from our perspective too it's like what
the hell are you doing you're talking
about multiple intelligences in the face
of all this documentation that
intelligence is actually a unitary
construct and you can't measure it at
all and now you're putting this forward
as the basis for some kind of
educational doctrine that was also
politically shocking well the Gardner
had written a book on the the emergence
of cognitive neuroscience
and in that book I don't recall the
title of the book
um he identified faculties in the mind
that the neuropsychologists had had that
cognitive Neuroscience had uh uncovered
and then his next that was a successful
book his next book after that was frames
of mind
um which is multiple intelligences book
and I think that what he essentially did
was
there's a very weird thing amongst
um academic psychologists I've always
found this striking
um the people that they value the most
are the people who are the most
intelligent you can see this in the way
they interact with their students
they're unaware of it many times but
it's it's it's quite noticeable
um but then as I said they don't like
the whole idea they um there's a
presumption that I think it might be if
I may be a bit Freudian about it there
might be an unconscious recognition that
they are conflating intelligence with
value as a human right with moral virtue
with moral virtue but just as just with
value and and that leads them to
um to see this conflation everywhere
even though other people aren't doing it
um I personally don't consider people to
be more valuable if they have a higher
IQ score but I think that there's there
may be some sort of guilt at the bottom
behind that I never really understood it
so what Gardner did was he plucked the
the the the the construct intelligence
out of the psychometric
realm and in the psychometric realm
intelligence and IQ are very clearly
understood there are very clear
procedures
for having these phenomenon phenomena
appear as construct in your statistical
analysis tool set
to put it as precisely as I can but he
just took that and said reducing if I
remember correctly it was something
along the lines of reducing
um the sort of prospect of a young
person down to one number an IQ score is
is of
is UN unreasonably cruel which he
offered and he said Jay Gould was making
the same kind of arguments right in the
midst appointment of man what Gardner
didn't do and he should have done and I
would and I would criticize him
ethically on this one is he didn't
explain that he was using a well-defined
individual difference psychometric
construct
and he was tearing that from that domain
and essentially appropriating the term
for his own
um rebranding of the faculties yeah
without without carrying through with
the required research that would be
necessary you want to call your frames
of mind intelligences you've got to show
me the tools
that will produce the spread of variance
so that you can use it as an individual
differences construct in your
statistical analysis for your research
project he never did that he just he
just hand waved it away he said well I'm
not interested in measurement it's like
well then you should shut the hell up
about intelligence and you should not
pollute the entire educational
psychology literature with your
Preposterous propositions multiplying a
construct that's already extremely well
understood technically and muddying up
the waters like um unforgivably in some
real sense and Stephen J Gould did the
same thing you know when he talked about
the mismeasure of man and I'd started to
understand with my limited statistical
and mathematical ability started to
understand factor analysis and the sorts
of things that we were pursuing more and
more mathematically deeply and I thought
well Stephen J Gould is criticizing the
hypothetically abstract construct of
intelligence it's like well what's the
abstract construct here well it's a
single Factor oh he's criticizing the
idea that the average of a group of
numbers is real
because really what what it boils down
to just so everybody who's listening
knows if if you take a hundred questions
any questions that require abstraction
to answer
and so they could be formally and
verbally say or pictorially in some kind
of abstraction if you ask a hundred
people a hundred questions and you sum
up their answers and you rank order the
people in terms of their accuracy you've
already produced what's essentially a
test of General cognitive ability it's
that robust and so IQ in some sense is
the rank ordering of people in
relationship to their ability to ask AB
to answer abstract questions or to learn
abstract Concepts corrected for age
that's all it is and it's a unitary
factor and so the idea that this is some
sort of statistical abstraction that
doesn't really exist is the same claim
that the average or the sum of a group
of numbers isn't real and any that's
preposterous scientifically
I thought ghoul's book was pretty
dishonest uh he used the the maxim that
correlation does not imply causation
which
you know
of course correlation implies causation
what it doesn't do is it doesn't
elucidate the causal mechanism
right it doesn't prove causation and so
essentially he jumped from there to the
idea that um that uh because this um
statistical regularity uh didn't it
could you couldn't point to a brain area
that we had illegitimately that people
had illegitimately reified it so all
right so on the entrepreneurial front
and this is where things got well
interesting and more complicated for all
of us
at the same time Daniel that we were
working together on the scientific front
we started talking about the possibility
of doing this commercially and so we
built a battery that
assessed people on the
neuropsychological front and had a
personality test built into it and you
tested it at Harvard and the University
of Toronto and Bob and I went on the
road to find companies that would allow
us to test it in the real world and that
was very tricky now Bob had a
brother-in-law who ran a factory in
Milwaukee Hatco and we went to Hatco and
we talked to the people there and said
look we're interested in predicting
industrial performance will you allow us
to conduct a study
in in your institution Bob do you want
to pick up the story there
sure well on numerous occasions we went
and uh we applied the battery of tests
to all the managers
basically that the entire staff and uh
it was it's a mid-size Corporation
and we uh went back what we did is to
validate it is we wanted to look at our
test results relative to the ratings
that the internal ratings of the
corporation which are done twice a year
I believe uh
and so we over a two-year period it was
that Jordan and I went and uh
tested individuals went through all the
data uh collected the data and passed it
on to Daniel
right right and so and then Daniel
published this well I think it was
brilliant thesis
bringing together the neuropsychological
literature the IQ literature the
personality literature and then laying
out these three extremely difficult
studies right it was hard to do the
studies at Harvard these were practical
real world studies it was difficult to
do them at the University of Toronto and
was difficult to do them on the
industrial front and you you published
that paper as you said in the Journal of
Personality and Social Psychology it's a
very highly ranked journal and uh I
remember the reviewers of your thesis
even though they weren't necessarily
politically aligned with with this
research protocol let's say were
uniformly uh extremely positive and with
regard to their comments on the quality
of the thesis I remember that uh a
couple of them told me afterwards that
that was one of the best thesis they had
ever read and it was something we had
very much thought about and still do
talk about from time to time making into
a book one of the things that was so
lovely about working with you Daniel is
something I like about engineers is that
you virtually never said anything you
hadn't researched right to the damn
bottom and you know if you're a computer
engineer you have to build something
from the code level up and it has to
work and one of the things I really
liked about you as a graduate student
was that I knew if you said you didn't
say a lot I had a lot I had students who
were a lot noisier than you and but if
you ever said something I knew perfectly
well that you had bloody well
investigated it right down to its atoms
and you knew the entire logical sequence
of ideation that produced that
conclusion remember for example you
referred to John Galton a fair bit in
your thesis and you actually went back
into the original writings and
familiarized yourself with Galton in a
manner that was well that distinguished
you distinguished you completely from
anybody I'd ever met who talked about
Golden at all your thesis was really a
masterpiece of of depth and courage and
clear thinking and so anyways we started
oh I had a side question for you why the
hell did you switch from engineering to
psychology like you came over to Harvard
and took my class and I don't remember
exactly did you start working with me
when you were still an undergraduate as
an undergraduate project how did why did
you come over and start working with me
I mean you were perfectly qualified
engineering on the computational front
you had a you know an immense potential
career set out in front of you
well I had been reading uh I had been
reading uh Carl Jung and Sigmund Freud
and Alfred Adler and stuff like that and
um and I had taken I I ordered it it was
psychos at uh at MIT so I went over
there to take your personality
psychology class and um and then I went
up and talked to you afterwards and said
um this is interesting what do you do
you know shall we do something together
and you said yeah sure why don't you
um why didn't you construct this
instrument to help us I believe
um cook you know um code reactions of
people who are in an alcohol
experiment with the computer and then it
just went on from there then we did the
first version of the neurocognitive
battery
um then before we went to Hatco Etc we
did we redid it to make it more
intuitive
um and easier to use remember the summer
in I think it was 1998 yeah you and
Alice and I were in Porter Square
working on that stuffing ourselves with
pastries in the mid-morning Good Times
and that was just at the dawn of the
point where all this stuff became
possible on the computational front so
that was exciting too to learn how to do
all that right oh just um to clarify
something it wasn't the the people at
the jpsp said that the um that the paper
that this submission was well written it
was the people at Harvard
um that that gave the positive feedback
I don't think you should be smirching
the people that jpsb by suggesting that
they thought there was anything
particularly special about my paper
right right no no it was it was the
reviewers of the thesis at Harvard yes
that's right all right so we we started
then Bob and I once your paper came out
we could calculate the economic return
that would be available to companies if
they used our test battery so basically
what we showed was that on the
managerial front if you
were scored highly on the
neuropsychological assessment
so which is something like an elaborated
assessment or no something like a
variant assessment of fluid intelligence
and you were high in conscientiousness
that you were
much more likely to be a successful
manager and that what predicted on the
line worker front was more purely just
conscientiousness and that was in
accordance with the relevant industrial
organization literature which we also
had to master at the same time right
because we were trying to find out what
were valid predictors of industrial
performance and to calculate the
economic Returns on that and we we armed
ourselves with a set of scientific facts
so what Bob and I and you decided to do
was to go out into the corporate world
and try to sell these tests and the
pitch was we can assess your new
employees within about an hour and a
half
we can tell you who's going to be a good
manager who statistically more likely we
can identify a pool of people who are
statistically more likely to be high
performers as managers and as line
workers using slightly different
measurement techniques and the economic
payoff of that is going to be like 500
times as much as it costs you to do the
testing per year over the hypothetical
five-year period of their career and we
used that five-year period because
people tend to switch jobs and so in our
naivety we presume that if we could go
out into the corporate world and say
look here's something that you could do
that is really inexpensive that will
generate a lot of money that people
would just fall all over themselves to
do it and so Bob you and I went on the
corporate Road for God
five years do you think
trying to sell these damn tests
and what was the consequence
zero
um
experience and uh
traveler points
pretty much right
the the uh I recall our trips uh to
Chicago Phoenix
um we we even uh went to a National
Football League team
and tried to sell them the test
and they were very interested but uh
right well they were using IQ tests eh
yeah but but the big problem with them
was they they figured they would have
difficulty getting the players to sit
down and actually uh invest an hour and
a half at any one time
right right right yeah well it turns out
that the better quarterbacks tend to
have better General cognitive ability
tend to have higher IQs yeah so what so
that was also our first encounter Bob
with the realities of human resources
and we used to joke
Bob and I met a tremendous number of
women employed in HR named Debbie and
they always got in our way like we would
we would attempt to lay out the case
that we could evaluate people on the
basis of their capacity to learn and
that that was that was an element of
Merit and the Debbies weren't very happy
with that idea because they like to
presume that you could train anybody to
do anything at all and there was no such
thing as individual differences and well
we probably talked to
300 companies something like that mostly
at the middle management level and what
did we learn we learned talking to
Middle managers is absolutely pointless
if you're trying to do anything
entrepreneurial well we learned that if
you're a middle manager go ahead Bob we
were devified yes exactly exactly and I
think that's been replaced by the
epithet Karen now and so other people
obviously encountered more Karen's but
we encountered a lot of Debbie's and so
well we learned that talking to Middle
managers about anything entrepreneurial
wasn't going to fly and the reason for
that was that most people in middle
management are not Risk Takers at all
and so if you go to them and you say
look we've got this new thing that could
have a spectacular outcome
all they hear is
I could get a lot in a lot of trouble if
that goes wrong and the only question
they really want to have answered is who
else is using this
and that was so interesting
sociologically because I didn't realize
at that point how much people relied on
consensus to make their judgments
instead of logic like as naive
scientists we assume that if we just
went out the business World armed with
our statistical arguments we could
demonstrate incontrovertibly the
economic utility of this approach but
then we assumed that people were
motivated by economic utility that they
would be rewarded for taking a risk that
they would understand the technical
arguments and that that would guide
their decision making and every single
one of those presumptions was wrong
yeah so we didn't sell any of those
tests not really not until we started
working with the founder Institute and
that was like 10 years later
well and the experience I had trying to
demonstrate to Pharmacists and uh to
pharmacies I I did we did studies with
uh pharmacies who made medication errors
serious errors and were able to
demonstrate that on this battery of
tests those individuals who made the
errors compared to a control group of
Pharmacists scored significantly poorly
particularly in something like working
memory because they just weren't able to
keep a lot of things in their head at
the one time and a pharmacist's job is
one which is very dependent on being
able to
keep in mind that they're filling a
prescription at the same time that they
have to deal with a customer at the same
time that there's a phone call is that
all of these uh situations that are
occurring anyway our our tests were
really appropriate in being able to
raise red flags about individuals who
are going to have trouble
and uh
so we even talked to large
pharmaceutical chains
at the directors of personnel level and
uh the issue is they didn't like our
tests a because of the time and B
because there was no face validity right
right they didn't look like yeah yeah
they didn't look like what a pharmacist
was doing
right right right yeah and so that as
Bob pointed out that's known as face
validity the test looks like it's doing
what it says to be doing and lots of
accurate psychological tests don't have
that quality so we also started to
understand more about the political
landscape on the corporate front in
America and and also why Innovative
Technologies are difficult to get
adopted I mean first of all if you're
going to go out and sell something to a
corporation you have to actually talk to
the people who can make decisions and
that is not an easy thing to do and
that's almost never middle management
and before people think that I'm down on
middle managers I I should also point
out that
um they have every reason to be leery of
risk so I remember one company that we
dealt with they were growing by like 100
employees a month they couldn't keep up
and they really needed
a technology to screen
their applicants before interviews and
our technology was perfectly situated to
manage this but um we wanted to charge
them I think it was thirty dollars a
test or something I think they had a
budget of five dollars and we said look
we just can't do it for five dollars
there's just no utility in this
whatsoever for us and we already
demonstrated that you'll get like a 500
to 1 return on investment at the price
we are charging why the hell wouldn't
you do it and they said well look
we get evaluated on how much we spend
per test and some other part of the
company will be rewarded if there's more
productive people so we Bear all the
responsibility for the risk and get none
of the reward for the outcome and I
thought well oh my God that's fatal and
so many companies are set up like that
like you're not going to get your HR
people to be incentified to hire better
employees if they get punished for
taking risks when they're assessing them
and so well we learned a lot about how
the corporate world functioned and and
also I I learned for example why why
people when they're making business
deals go play golf
for example and the reason for that is a
lot of the way that people in business
evaluate one another for the possibility
of working together is on the basis of
personal trust and compatibility like
they're not doing a technical analysis
of the utility of their processes hardly
anyone thinks like that right some
scientists think like that some of the
time but other people use all sorts of
interpersonal heuristics that we were in
some ways unaware of when we were
overestimating the degree to which pure
logic could be used as a sales technique
in any case Bob and I went all over
the US and Canada for a long time
a long long time learning about the
culture of business feeling like
complete bumbling fools because of
course we hadn't didn't really have any
business experience at that point and
then
well then we then two things happened
I made contact with the deoresi at the
founder Institute in California and
Adele was trying to set up business
schools for budding entrepreneurs all
over the world and he really wanted to
predict entrepreneurial ability and so
we ran a study with him that we never
published it was a private study for us
showing that we could actually predict
entrepreneurial performance with a quite
a high degree of accuracy and then we
started testing people all over the
world with a modified version of our
neuropsychological battery a much
simplified version that concentrated
more on fluid intelligence than on
hypothetical prefrontal ability and we
tested tens of thousands of people for a
Dale quite successfully and that kept
exam core going
now that was it was hard on the business
Frontier because we pulled Daniel into
the business and we we tried to fund his
research through grants and we threw
some private funding at him although we
didn't have a lot of money and and we're
generating any capital and that
you know at that time
the universities were really pushing on
professors to
to uh commodify their research why can't
the universities produce more businesses
and we went out and tried to produce a
business and what we learned was that's
a hell of a lot harder than you think
because the product is only about five
percent of the problem
sales and marketing are more like 95
percent of the problem and we also
learned that the the people who were
pushing this idea that
scientists should produce more
businesses were people who never
discovered anything scientifically and
had no idea how difficult that was and
it would never produced a business and
who had no idea how difficult that was
and then had absolutely no idea
whatsoever about how difficult it was to
jointly do something scientific and
entrepreneurial and the reason for that
in part is those are very different
domains like marketing and sales is such
a big part of the of the industrial uh
um domain of activities compared to the
scientific you have to understand
marketing and sales deeply to be
successful as an entrepreneur
and uh
and also we also ran into a fair bit of
friction
it was often very emotionally demanding
because we had in some sense a conflict
of interest especially in relationship
to Daniel because we were trying to move
ahead your scientific career and we were
trying to produce a business Enterprise
at the same time and it wasn't easy at
all
to keep the the ethical lines straight
you know how much to pay you how much we
should be concentrating on your
scientific career now you had gone
somewhat disenchanted with the idea of a
scientific career but we're very
interested in pursuing the development
of this battery and at the same time
just to make the story a bit more
complex a lot of the
um
managers we were talking to
they would dispense with any interest in
the predictive tests
um for the reasons we already described
but they kept asking us the same
question which was well
you say we should hire better people but
we have a lot of troublesome people that
we've already hired and we need to know
what to do with them
and our answer always was well we don't
know what to do with your Troublesome
people and the managerial literature
says you should spend all the time with
your best performers not your worst and
so
we don't know what to do about that
maybe there's nothing that can be done
but we got asked that like 200 times
and so we went into the literature to
see if we could find
any evidence that there were broad-scale
psychological interventions that might
help poorer performers
and we settled on
the development of what became the
self-authoring battery
and we learned that from two different
literatures James penabaker spearheaded
one of them and then lock them in late
lock them and
Latham and Locke
um Gary Latham
did that in the goal setting domain in
the industrial organizational psychology
we we found out that if you had people
write about complex
about the complexities of their life
autobiographically or in relationship to
their future
that they would perform better
industrially and their mental and
physical health would improve so we
started working with Adele to predict uh
creative competence and that gave us a
bit of capital and then we started to
develop the I think that was the right
order we started to develop the
self-authoring tests and
our goal was to produce tests that were
scientifically validatable that were
inexpensive that were scalable that
would do no harm in that had
demonstrated validity in terms of
improving performance and mental health
and so Daniel you want to walk through
the self-authoring suite A little bit
yeah the self-authoring suite is
essentially a series of writing
exercises future authoring past
authoring and present authoring and
starting with I'd like to start with the
future authoring because it's um it
gives you the most bang for your buck
and essentially it's a series of um of
writing exercises where you're asked to
think about what you want out of
um out of life
in concrete in more concrete detail than
you do typically and to work out some
processes
um to elaborate on that on that vision
of an ideal future and then to actually
break up the um
the steps that would be required in
order for you to start making making
motion towards that and then to look at
the impediments and things that can help
you to execute those plans
um and so the future authoring is a is
is a good way to get people motivated
and I think maybe
um maybe you might uh talk in some
detail about the study that we did at
the college because you're a little bit
more familiar with the details of that
than I am
we'll be back in one moment first we
wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new documentary logos and
literacy
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripture memorization today exists only
because of what is sung
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the Press of Johann gooper science
and religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and medicine and science to to
civilization itself it is the most
influential book in all history and
hopefully people can walk away with at
least a sense of that
yeah well we did three studies uh you
and I and Bob did all these studies and
so Bob had a student who was working at
McGill
who was interested in
potentially in the prediction of
performance and so we set out to see if
we allowed students or encourage
students to write about their future to
make a plan to develop a vision for
seven six dimensions of their future
Intimate Relationships job Career
Education care of mental and physical
health use of time outside of work
regulation of of response to Temptations
um friendship networks development of
friendship networks to develop a
coherent plan for those domains
um in relatively constrained
circumstances right I think we had
people write for 90 minutes or write
about what they had done the previous
two weeks for 90 minutes and then we
evaluated first at McGill we evaluated
the impact of a goal setting program on
academic performance and we found that
we
decreased the dropout rate
and these are fairly highly selected
students at McGill because it's a
selective University we dropped their
dropout rate substantially and we
increased their academic performance by
35 percent
and you know you'd expect that
universities would just jump all over
that it's like that's a walloping
Improvement in performance and although
they didn't that's for sure and then we
did some work with Michaela shippers in
the Netherlands at the business school
there and ran another series of studies
uh over a couple of years showing that
we got exactly the same results for
undergraduate Business Schools but that
the results were even more pronounced
for men who were underperforming men in
general were underperforming and even
more specifically for minority men so it
was this weird intervention most
interventions
psychological interventions help people
who aren't doing well do somewhat better
but at the same time they help people
who are doing well do even better but
this intervention
had this paradoxical effect where it
really raised the bottom part of the
performance distribution and the the
Calmar the culminating
study in that sequence of studies we did
at Mohawk College and we had kids come
in for their orientation day and write
for 90 minutes about their future or
write about what they did for the past
two weeks and we dropped their dropout
rate 50 percent the first year which was
and that was mostly and it worked best
for the men who had the lowest grades in
high school and for minority men again
and so we thought well this is just a
no-brainer people are going to eat this
up like mad because well why wouldn't
you want a intervention that's Dirt
Cheap that reduces Dropout by 50 percent
and particularly targets minority men
like what a deal for everyone regardless
of your politics and we worked with
mohawk for what 10 months afterwards
retooling our damn software to fit their
bureaucratic idiocy and at the end of
that which was a lot of trouble for us
they just dropped it yeah that was
hilarious I I really thought that was
very funny yeah yeah well and also very
telling man it's like
it's like cheap that took no time that
had no negative side effects that
doubled the performance of your incoming
students and then and we offered it to
you with almost no difficulty and
retooled it for your bureaucracy and we
did the study in your institution and we
published it and yet at the end of this
whole process you basically told us that
you weren't interested it's like yeah
you you're bloody well not interested
that's why you have such a high dropout
rate among young men because you don't
give a damn and that's pretty much the
situation in universities writ large
so so what we decided to do Bob what we
decided to do instead was just to sell
this program the individual say and we
just stopped we just stopped talking to
corporations and large institutions all
together and that was way better like we
have a pretty steady sales
record now we also produced a
personality test called
understandmyself.com
that enables people to go and do a Big
Five personality analysis gives them a
detailed report on their personality and
also they compare up with a partner an
intimate partner say and they can to go
do the test and get their own report and
then they can get a joint report
detailing out their similarities and
their differences and what Daniel how
many
how many self-authoring programs are we
selling a day and and how many
understand myself programs are we
selling a day on average now about uh I
I I'm not sure I I can tell you that in
aggregate we've probably done about six
hundred thousand five to six hundred
thousand understand myself
um users and possibly
um maybe four hundred thousand
self-authoring but I could be wrong well
no it's a couple hundred a day anyways
on on a regular basis say and the the
feedback we've been getting from people
with regards to understand myself is
very positive people find the provision
of accurate personality information
about themselves extremely useful and
also on the partnership on the partner
fronti because we only launched that
what about
how long ago did we put the
the couple's version of the personality
test stop
I think it was 2020. 2021 maybe right
right so that hasn't been going that
long and people Tammy and I did that and
did a podcast about it and we even
though we know each other well and we
designed you know I designed at least
part of the damn test I still found
doing it with her quite revealing and it
helped us understand each other better
because it's a wonderful thing you are
different go ahead Daniel the wonderful
thing about the understand myself uh
process is that it gives it gives our
users what you could call immediately
actionable
like insight into into
um
into what they're like and how they
respond to to to various situations and
it's it doesn't require the same amount
of time commitment as the self-authoring
so
um so it's very it's it's actually quite
a pleasant um experience
um and I won't say that for let's say
the past authoring
um right right the people who get the
most value from the past authoring don't
enjoy doing it they um and sometimes
they even get angry at us for asking
them to do it but they understand myself
is immediately
um is immediately helpful and I think
it's immediately rewarding as well
right well the past authoring you know
there's a good dictum from Clinical
Psychology that it's better to
voluntarily face your demons let's say
or the dragons right it's
you you put yourself in the zone of
proximal development by adopting a a
voluntary stance of confrontation with
complexity and threat and one of the
things we asked people in the past
authoring exercise to do is to divide
their life into sections epochs and then
to write about the more emotionally
compelling experiences right both
negative and positive and yeah that's
quite difficult and it does upset people
I mean the research literature indicated
most of this generated by pennebaker and
his and the people who followed in his
footsteps basically showed that if you
do an autobiographical exercise like
that which is Akin in some sense to both
confession and to psychotherapy is that
the immediate consequences are negative
because reliving those
upsetting experiences is upsetting and
can put you into a bit of a spin but the
medium to long-term consequences are
very positive both on the performance
and on the mental and physical health
front and so you can think of
self-awther all of those of you who are
watching and listening you can think of
this self-authoring.com set of exercises
the self-authoring suite as
what would you say as it's in some sense
do it yourself
well Redemption but certainly do it
yourself Psychotherapy and you know
maybe it couldn't substitute for
extremely high quality
Psychotherapy conducted by someone who
really knows what he or she is doing but
it's a pretty damn good
home
activity if you want to set your life
straight and I mean
I think our the response we've had from
the individuals who've been using it
well you deal with that more because
you've handled customer complaints and
comments for years like what's I have
lots of people in my lectures who come
up to me and tell me you know how
helpful they understand myself program
was but also the self-authoring program
fewer people because it's more difficult
but people often respond to the
self-authoring program in a manner that
indicates you know that it's changed
their life and I used the programs we
developed the programs from my maps of
meaning course at the U of T right when
we were first walking through the paper
and pencil versions I had students write
autobiographies and then also write out
a plan for the future and I could watch
the impact that it had on them it's
really something to be able to develop a
vision for the future
go ahead if any users are watching this
and um you know I would say with the
with the self-authoring suite because we
all have a limited amount of time in a
limited amount of energy and so if you
if you're not sure that that you can
that you can do the full thing do the
future authoring and do it badly
and push through it to the very end if
you're doing the past authoring
and you think you can only do a little
bit at a time do a little bit at a time
and then walk away from it come back to
it re-read it take your time over that
one they're really quite different I
don't think people should approach them
the same way uh push the future
authoring through to the end and then
you can redo it again later if you want
to
um but with the past authoring if it's
difficult just do a little bit set it
aside come back to it again later it'll
be waiting for you when you're ready
yeah right don't bite off more than you
can chew there's no need to there's no
need to
so yeah so so while we were pretty happy
with the way the the self-authoring and
the understand myself tests have rolled
out because we were able to fulfill our
vision we should talk a little bit guys
about some of the problems that we've
encountered trying to keep our
relationship intact over this 30-year
period I mean we hit a lot of situations
I mean it's been a pleasure overall and
a real intellectual adventure and a
personal adventure and rewarding in 15
different ways but man we hit some
pretty brutal points of conflict over
the years too especially when we were
trying to
bring new people into the Endeavor and
also to retool our financial agreement
say because Daniel you sort of started
out as a junior partner in some sense
and then
well as our Enterprise developed
and and you developed the tech the
technology of the platform and and
plenty of the underlying ideas Your Role
grew and and then we had to retool our
financial arrangements to take that into
account and that was every time we've
had to
address our constitutional agreement and
let let's say that's caused really weeks
and even months of a fair bit of
emotional turmoil for all of us
it's not an easy thing to to figure out
exactly what's fair and and to be able
to maintain that across time what are
your memories of those processes Daniel
the process of me insidiously taking
over the whole company
yeah yeah yeah exactly that
um
generally speaking the we we had to go
through these
we had to go through these all right so
one of the things that I didn't want to
happen was I didn't want to be involved
in a failed company
and the and from my intuition was that
if we took on funding from outside
um and we tried to grow the way
companies tend to do that we would that
we would be dead in six months if we
didn't have something happening
something significant happening on sales
and I was always attracted to the small
business model rather than the big shot
Venture Capital sort of you know story
and so that basically required um us to
do the work ourselves and
um I guess what what happened was when
we first started there was a I think
there was kind of like a basic
presumption was that we would be sort of
doing this the way most businesses do it
they get funding they hire people they
pay them and so on
but
approaching it as a small business thing
where all of the partners are doing
with the work
um the partners that are doing the most
work exclusively on it are the ones that
are taking on the most risk if you think
of the opportunity cost and so that
basically required
um you know
over time recognizing that and then
deciding that it would a the first thing
was is it is it right for us to try this
small business approach where we do
things ourselves or should we do the the
the funding route and then be what's
required in order to make it so that
everybody involved is going to be
sufficiently
um represented as a player if you like
based on their risk and um I think it
took it was difficult I think because a
good deal of the stuff that happens
um neither you nor Bob would see it
happening you would be giving giving a
lecture and I would be pounding my head
against the keyboard because I can't
find out what this ridiculous bug is or
whatever the case may be and and so it
was it wasn't easy for everyone to see
exactly what was going was going on I
had a pretty good idea what was
happening because just
about a lot of the stuff outside of the
business up outside of the sales things
which which I wasn't part of was
happening through me and a lot of the
re-negotiations happened after we had
decided that the um that the rubber
chicken route
um of going to conferences and so on
wasn't going to work
so
um and so that was it and I think that
it was a lot of that was basically I
suppose you could say it was driven by a
certain aggressiveness on my part I
thought it was I thought it was
necessary and I tried not to be too
aggressive about it and essentially you
guys graciously kind of acquiescing to
my request more like honesty on your
part on in two ways eh so the first
honesty and this was really interesting
you know I'm probably more market and
sales oriented Bob probably is too than
you and I mean that's kind of how it's
laid itself out in the company and so we
would be more expansive we had a more
expansive proclivity on the sales and
growth front and Bob and I learned this
too because we we did concept we did
consider going down the Venture Capital
route and so that route is something
like well you have an idea and you test
it and you get initial funding from
family and friends and so forth and then
you're ready to launch your idea broadly
into the world world and so you bring in
Venture Capital you hire a whole bunch
of people you try to build your company
into something that has a very a
staggering sort of valuation and then
maybe you go public and you cash out and
you have your margaritas and you sit on
the beach and in Guadalupe if there's a
beach there for the rest of your life
and uh that's your vision and you were
very much opposed to that practically
but I think there was an ethical element
too and Bob and I got quite deeply into
the whole venture capitalist and Tech
incubator scene both in the U.S and
Canada and what I realized eventually
was that it was almost all scam that
mostly what these so-called Tech
incubator companies were doing were was
hype now I'm ambivalent about that
because I have some real respect for
marketing and sales people
where you have to communicate about your
product and push it forward but the
degenerate element of that is is the
kind of narcissism right and we got
tangled up a couple of times with tech
incubators who were working with some of
the junior people that we tried to work
with who filled their heads with visions
of a 400 million dollar initial public
offering and this immense amount of
wealth and failed entirely to educate
them about the fact that if you really
wanted to start a business you should go
out and find some damn customers because
that's the hardest part of of a business
and you were very good at continually
insisting that we didn't do that that we
that we kept our vision I wouldn't say
small but not grandiose and you were
also extremely good at letting us know
when
the financial arrangement we had worked
out was no longer
sufficiently motivating for you for you
to be wholeheartedly committed to this
project and I would say of the three of
us I mean you've staked your life on our
business Enterprise to a larger degree
than either Bob or I have by a
substantial margin and you know we
needed to know when you needed to be
properly compensated for that so I don't
think that was aggressive aggression Bob
what do you think about like what did
you see as the major challenges in
keeping our Enterprise going and our
relationship over the last 30 years and
why do you think we're able to do it
successfully
well I I think we basically listened to
Daniel
and uh understood what the issue was
um and uh we need to be anchored to
reality and Daniel was that anchor and
the anchor wasn't being sufficiently
rewarded yeah well you you were the one
in in some sense that that paid the most
price for that technically because as
Daniel's role in the company grew
um proportionately your ownership of the
company shrank proportionately mine did
to some degree but not as much as yours
did and so you know I mentioned at the
beginning of the conversation that one
of the reasons I really enjoyed working
with you and thought it was such a
privilege
out McGill
was that you were very very fair and
judicious in your distribution of
rewards and credits and
you know you you showed that same
rather largeness of spirit let's say
when we had to undergo these
renegotiations and
um well that's obviously worked out very
well for everybody that we've been able
to serve with these programs but also
for the three of us because this is
especially over the last four or five
years this has turned into a very robust
and reliable business and so Daniel I
don't think it was aggression that's not
how I look at it like I really think it
was a form of the same kind of rigorous
honesty that you've brought to the
programming Enterprise because you've
produced an unbelievably reliable system
like I don't think we we haven't lost
any data and I don't think we've ever
been offline except when the Microsoft
servers crashed
and so you brought that in Integrity of
purpose to your intellectual Endeavor on
the on the academic front and then to
your engineering but also to your you
had an unerring eye for what the
difficult but appropriate path forward
was on the business front and so that's
been extremely useful and luckily as Bob
pointed out we had enough sense to pay
attention to that and to adjust when
that was necessary
it got very challenging again when
things kind of blew up around me and I
got sick because you ended up both of
you ended up dealing not with me so much
as with my proxies and well that put
another
and we also didn't really know what to
do with the fact that I had come to such
broad public attention at that point too
and how to reconfigure Bob and I just
decided Bob and I just decided that we
were going to take advantage of it just
we have meetings where we talk hey Bob
have you contacted Jordan lately because
you know we want to make sure that he
still thinks we are his friend
we want to be able to provide this guy's
coattails
when you were talking about the VC thing
um you know occasionally a very large
window birds will often try to fly
through the window and they they hit the
window and fall well watching you and
Bob trying to sell exam Corp was a
little bit like that and so whenever
whenever somebody said
oh hey this is a big let's do a business
plan let's do this let's do that
um
and you take a look at the sales
situation it wasn't very difficult to
see like what would be different about
these people why wouldn't these also be
Birds bouncing off a glass window and I
didn't see it it wasn't it wasn't easy
to it wasn't difficult
all I had to do was say well um you all
I had to do was basically trust that you
guys gave it a good go
and then just looking at these other
situations it was a very easy
calculation to make
um you know we're gonna be we're going
to be dead in six months because they're
not going to have any more success
making sales
um then we have to figure out a very
low-cost way of keeping this alive until
we figure out what the formula is and
then we did figure out what the formula
is largely uh you you did an experiment
um I don't remember exactly when it was
but you just basically uh put the
self-authoring suite online you put
together a website with a very simple
PayPal button and that gave us a proof
of concept and from that point forward
it was just like um
oh we'll just deal with end users
they're great they come to us they want
to use it they love it sometimes they
complain to us about the self-authoring
suite being a little bit more painful
than they were expecting
um but um but there's no more but but
there was no more of this um you know
trying to deal with a corporate
structure and being bounced back down to
HR and then booted out the door yeah but
we were able to do that because a lot of
the businesses they have no issue at all
and this is also this is more of a
function of the size of the business
they will waste your time
right without giving it a second thought
and so once we started going to end
users it was better
well we were we were on the threshold of
large business deals several times like
we had a a contract pending with a very
large organization in New York for the
self-authoring suite and it was
literally on the CEO's desk for
Signature and thank God it didn't go
through because we would have ended up
as employees of this company and we we
didn't charge nearly enough money for
what we wanted to do in our ignorance
and the CEO resigned that day and that
had taken us like a year of work to
organize that deal and it just
evaporated and that happened to us like
we did have some sales successes in nine
out of 10 of the initial stages you know
but that was another thing about uh
about um
the complexity of dealing with
corporations is that you know you think
you want to land a big fish and there's
a lot of money in that but it takes a
lot of time and there's such churn in
turnover in corporations that you can
end up talking to someone for like a
year and then all of a sudden they're
not there anymore and that happened a
lot and and that that was certainly a
reason why selling to individuals was
better
I think our new market is great you
encounter these people all the time
they're it's so rewarding to provide
these services for them
um I get this through the um through the
emails that we get but you also meet
people at your events and um that's not
that I I don't think that we would have
done
I don't think we would have done better
if we were working in the corporate
world and working with end users no and
it would have been way more annoying
like the thing one of the things
everybody listening should understand is
that if you make a deal ever with anyone
who has more money than you
don't be so sure that you're not now an
employee
you know because you think well I'd like
to land a big company and they'd be my
client it's like yeah if the company is
a lot bigger than you they're not your
client you are now their minion and so
and maybe you want that right because
you have to have a job but don't don't
don't ever be convinced that there
aren't major strings that come along
with that one of the things I really
liked about you and also about working
with you Bob too on the entrepreneurial
front was that I think all three of us
were free enough of delusion to
understand pretty
immediately on the
industrial and corporate front that the
only thing that really mattered the only
thing that was truly real was the in
hand existence of paying customers
that's the fundamental metric is like I
don't care about how your idea sounds I
don't care about the background of your
team
Etc I don't care about your vision of
the future those things are all relevant
to some degree but what I do care about
is have you even been able to find one
person who will give you money for what
you're producing and and we did keep
that in mind and that is why we
eventually turn to private users yeah
people who want to improve themselves or
help themselves versus companies when we
were asking someone to help other people
who may not have particularly wanted to
be helped you know have everybody in the
department do the future authoring
program I remember being in school
uh well enough to know that I wouldn't
have liked that very much right but
right yeah well that's the advantage to
dealing with these individuals like you
said that's a voluntary it's a voluntary
association yes and they like it and
they they they want to do it and they
want to do it for themselves as well
each one of them is a um is a mini
victory
right right yeah well and it's a lovely
thing I mean one of the things that Bob
and I talked about a long time ago and
then obviously with you too is you know
we were interested right from the
beginning
in working on the entrepreneurial front
partly just because of the challenge of
learning how to do it and God knows we
learn plenty by going through the
difficulties of banging ourselves
against multiple sheets of glass window
and breaking our necks over and over and
over I mean our vision was to produce
widely distributable psychological
interventions at low cost with low
overhead that would not hurt anyone and
that would do people good and I think
that we we have managed that to a large
degree like the research we've done on
these interventions and measures has
been very solid and
it's certainly the case that the
hundreds of thousands of people who've
used our Technologies now have many of
them have set their lives on much more
productive Pathways and that's pretty
damn good thing to be able to to be to
have participated in and also to have
profited from and you know one thing
people who are a bit skeptical about
capitalism might be asking is well why
the hell didn't you just give away this
all for free how do we know this isn't
greed and we spent a lot of time talking
about the right price eh and it took us
a long time to figure out what our
self-authoring program was worth it's
like well if this is going to change
your life how much is it worth and the
answer to that was well it's worth about
what people will pay for it because
that's the actual accurate number and we
we sell it at quite a low cost I mean it
it's not the sort of thing that anybody
in the developed world is going to have
to strain themselves particularly to
afford but we decided not to distribute
it for free and we've never produced
anything for free we've always worked
within a for-profit model and for me the
advantage of that was twofold is like
we had to produce the kind of products
that people would actually pay for
so that was one way of demonstrating
their attractiveness and value and then
the other thing of course is because
we've been able to generate some Capital
as a consequence of doing this on a
for-profit basis we're not beholden to
any outside stakeholders governmental or
private and we have enough Capital so
that we can produce additional Ventures
and Daniel you're working on some on a
refitting for example of our predictive
battery do you want to maybe we'll just
wrap up with that do you want to just
end with a brief description of where
you're headed where we're headed in the
future sure but let me just add to what
you're saying um the people who are
users when they come they and they pay
for the assessments I wouldn't ask them
to do this for free because I think that
robs them of their agency
when they pay for it they can accept it
or reject it and if they don't like it
they can ask for their money back and
um and in my experience I don't think
people want free I think that's a
delusion of um of uh of the computer age
the internet age but I could be wrong
about that no I know I think that's
right I mean
it's it's the case often that if I do
offer content for free say that people
clamor to be involved in some manner
that allows them to reciprocate that's
the thing is people have a powerful
drive for reciprocity eh and so if you
offer something to someone for free well
first of all it begs the question Who
the hell's the product here like is it
really free and second it doesn't allow
people to discharge their moral burden
you know because people don't have to be
beholden to us for having done them a
favor and the reason for that is because
they paid us and as far as we're
concerned that's a perfectly equal and
desirable trade yeah it's respectful
yeah yeah
so the um basically what I'm working on
now and I suppose it'll probably be
something like um
sometimes hopefully over the next 12
years 12 months 12 years is a classic
Freudian slip there I that's definitely
Freudian
um but uh
it's it's to make it so that
um my my target audience for this is
small businesses if large corporations
want to use it it's fine as long as they
don't expect to call me on the phone
because I I don't want to go down that
rabbit hole again my target is small
businesses because we have a lot of
small business users that use understand
myself and self-authoring and they use
it informally they just go there they go
there on their own they purchase it they
distribute it to their people
it's all voluntary there's no there's no
hard sale or anything like that
um and so
um what I want to do is I want to
streamline it to make it easier for
small businesses and organizations like
churches and so on and so forth
um to be able to purchase the understand
myself
um and uh and um self-authoring for
their uh members or their their
employees whatever the case may be
um but also I'm going to use that
platform to essentially bring
um the harder edged we didn't talk about
selection that much we alluded to it
um the fastest and easiest way to
improve let's say your your your
Workforce is to use brutal selection
practices and everybody understood that
until about five minutes ago
um that's why you know Harvard and Yale
used to have brutal um selection
processes most people wouldn't wouldn't
their their application is in red
um and so uh so these ones so the
assessment things I'd like to be able to
bring those back to um to General use to
make them easier to use so that um so
that people can um can do it can use a
little bit of selection when they're
hiring people
so that
you know
to avoid the situation okay so we never
discussed this um but one of the least
effective ways of um determining the uh
let's say
cognitive ability is important for jobs
that are highly complex
and so it becomes more this becomes more
of an issue if you're talking about
highly complex jobs but one of the tools
that a lot of people use to determine
whether or not someone's a suitable fit
is an interview and the Hunter and
Schmidt research was quite plain that
interviews are not very useful unless
they're highly structured interviews or
even if they include some work sample
and so um this is to provide people with
an auxiliary of the uh to their whole
hiring process which may or may not
include cognitive ability but will
include the Big Five personality
assessment
um you know also and um and so the idea
then is is to make these tools available
for people to use at low cost
um with low commitment
and hopefully uh the advice that we'll
have for them will be use these tools to
bias your decision processes don't use
them to make your decisions just have
this just have these in the back your
head while you're talking to people
there's a lot you can derive from it for
example if you if you have a Big Five
personality assessment on somebody
before you interview them
it's very it would be very useful if
you're about to interview somebody who's
high in extroversion you need to know
that during that interview you're going
to have an inflated view of their
competence
because you will automatically conflate
confidence with confidence
so it's good to know before you go in
there whether or not you're dealing with
somebody who's highly extroverted if
they're highly extroverted they're going
to present better
compared to others and in the in the
opposite direction if somebody is high
in neuroticism it's good to know that in
advance they might not appear very
confident they might require a certain
amount of coats coaxing to um to come
out of their shell they might be nervous
it would be useful to have a tool to
know that in advance so you can
essentially
um
counteract the hard wiring that you have
as an interviewer to be Bamboozled by
the brilliant and to um to to
discard people who don't present
themselves in a forceful way right well
you you talked about brutal selection
methods and people might react to that
and I would say well here's something
for people to think about here's
something brutal hire stupidly and put
people in positions where not only do
they fail painfully over a long period
of time but they compromise the
performance of everyone around them
while doing so now that's brutal and
it's a lot more brutal than making an
appropriate hiring decision to begin
with and so it isn't whether it's brutal
or not it's like which form of brutality
do you prefer and I would prefer the
preventive brutality approach rather
than the consequential brutality
approach
well I think the I think what I I brutal
is probably uh
too wasn't it wasn't a good choice of
words but I think that it's essentially
if you're using
it's the opposite would be to have a
therapeutic View
that you can essentially change people
and you can convert them into something
that they're not for example and let's
just keep it in the personality realm
you might have a highly agreeable person
somebody who's very high in compassion
and that person has been hired by a law
firm let's say and all of a sudden this
person has to go into situations where
they have to act in a very disagreeable
way
and um
you know the therapeutic way would be to
um presume that that person will change
over time and they can over time
um but uh but it might be better to uh
depending on your perspective to look
for people who are low in agreeableness
if you want to hire lawyers particularly
if they're going to be doing yeah
aggressive aggressive legal action
so um putting but putting the wrong
person in the wrong place particularly
in a complex environment where things
are interconnected like for example in
software they compare the most
productive workers to the least
productive workers and they try to work
out you know you can speculate on what
would be a factor of productivity and as
one person said the factor is infinite
because not only will it not only will
an unproductive worker not produce
they can actually introduce bugs and
errors into the system that takes more
capable people time to undo so they can
have a negative impact on the overall
situation yeah well the the the the
management literature that that I
reviewed and that was back in the 90s
indicated that 60 percent of managers
add negative net value to a given
corporate Enterprise
sixty percent right so it's not just
zero it's it's worse than zero and so so
and you also do less let me just add
this you do much less damage to somebody
by
um uh by not hiring them if they're not
appropriate than you do by letting them
in and then terminating them after six
months or 12 months right right right
right so you pay the eventual price for
inaccuracy in your determinations no
matter how compassionate that motivation
might be everybody has to pay the price
at the end even you boss man
Yeah Yeah well yeah no doubt Bob you're
going to come down to Miami and lecture
for Peterson Academy and so that's at
least part of what's On Your Horizon
when are you doing that
mid-February
oh good and and what are you're going to
do elect series of lectures on abnormal
psychology is that the plan yep it is
excellent excellent yeah and so for
everyone watching and listening this is
part of this Peterson Academy initiative
which is an attempt to produce something
approximating an online University at
least At The Bachelor of Arts level and
Bob is one of our Stellar uh uh uh
lecturers lined up to to work for this
Academy
um Bob was an excellent graduate student
advisor but I should also point out that
he's an extremely popular undergraduate
lecturer um he lectured about abnormal
psychology which of course is very
interesting field although any bad
lecturer can make any field dull and
uninteresting even abnormal psychology
but Bob was a stellar lecturer at Mcgill
and
um witty and Urbane and challenging and
um provocative and we're very happy to
have him have the opportunity to bring
those lectures to a much broader
audience we hope with the Peterson
Academy and so it's a great pleasure
talking to both of you guys today
um we covered a lot of the ground that
we've covered in the last three decades
and so that was very entertaining it's
been a privilege to work with both of
you and quite the honor to have been
able to produce a thriving Enterprise
despite the difficulties that has in
fact resulted in helping perhaps tens of
thousands and maybe hundreds of
thousands of people I mean that really
was a fulfillment of our initial Vision
right because I remember we established
these principles at the beginning of our
collaboration right is that we were
going to produce valid psychological
interventions and assessment methods
low-cost widely distributed scalable
inexpensive and Do no harm and that
we're also going to stay relatively
minimal on the uh employee front which
we have because there's basically us
three and and the person that you've
hired part-time to do customer service
and so it really looks like although it
took a long time for it to unfold and to
work it looks like we did hit the target
that we had eventually set and so and
continue to do that and so I'm going to
talk to Daniel and Bob a little bit more
on the daily wire plus platform about
how their interest in their respective
Fields developed and so for those of you
who are watching and listening that
might be interested in that you'll have
to refer to the Daily wire plus platform
for that I'd like to thank them for
facilitating this conversation and to
everyone watching and listening for your
time and attention wish everybody Happy
New Year and to say once again thank you
you too
thanks Jordan great ride all right so
ciao everybody yeah yeah it's so nice to
be able to sit and talk to you guys and
uh well we'll we'll finish this up on
the daily wire plus platform bye to
everybody watching and listening
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com